okay babe don't take this wrong way but
you've been crushing like way too hard
lately what are you talking about like
every time a girl shows you any kind of
attention you madly fall in love with
her it's ridiculous that is not true at
all hey guys how's it going
good baby
you got
to talk to the baby
good we're good huh what the hell was
that what you just went all googoo gaga
on Sheila I did not know you did I saw
you I found two eyes
well you're blind that's the stupidest
thing you've ever said Disney I think
it's a longer believe me when you see
nobody else cause no one's as true as
you and do what you want you you got
patience for let's face it the only way
to be serious
so you didn't think that was weird what
how you're just looking at why be in
music started playing everything was
moving in slow motion you heard that
term yeah you gotta stop it it's weird
okay you can't just be looking at every
single girl it's one of those good
no no oh
[Music]
[Music]